dafür setze ich kein quatsch männer
aus europa und anderen westlichen
regionen produzieren immer weniger
spermien gar nicht gut
die spermienanzahl pro milliliter
samenflüssigkeit ist in den vergangenen
40 jahren um mehr als 50 prozent
gesunken berichten jetzt medizinerinnen
und mediziner aus jerusalem und new york
was genau jetzt unseren spanien so zu
und bedeutet dieses ergebnis jetzt eine
gefahr für und westliche männer oder
sogar für die ganze menschheit das
alles erfahrt ihr jetzt mit blick zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
in der analyse der forscherinnen und
forscher aus new york und jerusalem sind
ganze 224 spermien zählungen aus 185
studien einbezogen
die innerhalb der letzten 40 jahre an
knapp 43.000 männern durchgeführt
worden waren also eine wirkliche riesige
datenbasis und das ergebnis ihrer
analyse die wie im fachmagazin human
reproduction update veröffentlicht
haben ist beunruhigend ein drastischer
rückgang der spermien bei männern aus
europa australien neuseeland und
nordamerika pro samenerguss haben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
einen rückgang der spermien gesamtzahl
von knapp 60 prozent errechnet pro
milliliter samenflüssigkeit sei die
spermienanzahl um mehr als 50 prozent
gesunken
das klingt schon wirklich nicht so gut
keine signifikanten veränderungen
konnte das forscherteam dagegen beim
männer aus anderen weltregionen wie
asien afrika und südamerika feststellen
das ergebnis ist gras und klingt
irgendwie auch besorgniserregend
überraschend und neu ist diese
erkenntnis allerdings nicht denn schon
seit jahrzehnten gibt es immer mehr
hinweise darauf dass etwas unserem
spermien schwer zusetzt so gibt es eine
wirklich große zahl an studien aus
verschiedenen ländern die den selben
schluss nahelegen die zahl der
männlichen samen geht zurück zudem
steigt der anteil von nicht normal
reformen in spanien zuletzt hatte ein
französisches forscherteam daten aus
einer langzeitstudie veröffentlicht
nach denen die spermienproduktion um
zwei prozent abnehme pro jahr
dieses ergebnis deckt sich in etwa mit
der jetzt veröffentlichten studie aus
jerusalem und new york deren analyse
einen jährlichen rückgang der
schwärmen anfang pro milliliter
samenflüssigkeit von 14 prozent bei
westlichen man keine angabe zu gehen
dann zeigt aber was genau ist die
ursache für den spermien schon das
lässt sich aus den studien leider nicht
ablesen ist es stress medikamente oder
übergewicht aber auch handystrahlung
oder chemikalien die beispielsweise in
weichmacher oder pflanzenschutzmitteln
stecken und den hormonhaushalt
beeinflussen könnten den spermien zu
setzen all diese aspekte stehen
tatsächlich im verdacht und werden
nicht erst seit der aktuellen studie aus
new york und jerusalem
heftig diskutiert konsens in der
fachwelt also übereinstimmung besteht
aber darüber dass wärme dem
kühlsystem der hoden und damit auch der
sperma produktion schreiben kann wer
plant ein kind zu zeugen kann durch den
verzicht auf enge unterhosen warme
bäder saunagänge und sitzheizung seine
schwärmer qualität positiv
beeinflussen
als wissenschaftlich gesichert gilt auch
das rauchen den spermien schade der
studienleiter aus jerusalem h glühwein
versieht seine ergebnisse als zitat
dringenden legkow für forscher und
gesundheitsbehörden auf der ganzen welt
ja und tatsächlich wissen wir alle
für die männliche fruchtbarkeit wind
spermien unabdingbar und von
unschätzbarem wert auch wenn solche
ergebnisse die gesundheitsbehörden
sicherlich aufhorchen lassen einen grund
zur panik sehen reproduktionsmediziner
trotzdem nicht denn die konkreten zahlen
liegen immer noch weit über den werten
die die weltgesundheitsorganisation whu
als untergrenze zur zeugungsfähigkeit
angibt die untergrenze des normalbereich
liegt bei der spermien gesamtzahl von 39
millionen
laut aktuellen studien betrug sie im
jahr 2011 bei westlichen männern
achtung ohne kinder nachweis bei 107 5
millionen abgesehen von der spermien
anfang ist zudem ihre beweglichkeit und
ob sie eine normale form oder
fehlbildung aufweisen
von großer bedeutung beide faktoren
wurden in der aktuellen studie jetzt
nicht wirklich ich dennoch die aktuelle
studie bestärkt den trend der
kontinuierlich nachlassenden
spermienanzahl in den letzten
jahrzehnten das studienergebnis legt
außerdem nach dafür mit den
lebensumständen in den westlichen
industrienationen zu tun hat denn wie
sonst kann es sein dass bei männern aus
anderen regionen dieser welt keine
unterschiede zu früher festgestellt
worden wird es wartet also für den mann
selbst und auch für die menschheit
besteht aktuell keine gefahr wohlgemerkt
aktuell dennoch ist es wichtig dass wir
brauchen bleiben um möglichst schnell
die ursache für unseren spermien
schwund zu identifizieren pixum halte
ich euch natürlich auf dem laufenden
wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann sollten wir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesslich den
genau auf den glockner hier geht es
weiter mit sex und liebe chemie da geht
es um die chemie die nötig ist bevor es
überhaupt zum samenerguss kommen kann
aber sehr interessant nichtverpackungen
unbedingt darauf liegen ansonsten bis
dann bleib dran und viel spaß bei dem
video